foreign
t on Spike protein yeah that does our
friend Clayton Fox exactly yes who has
done an excellent analysis in which he
goes back through the dark days in which
I in particular and Robert Malone were
accused of
spreading misinformation for claiming
the spike protein was cytotoxic on Dark
Horse
and the point is of course Spike protein
is cytotoxic there was nothing bizarre
about that claim at the time yes you
could Marshal a counter argument based
on the fact that the protein wasn't the
identical one in the coronavirus itself
it had been locked open but as I
remember there was research and I could
have to go back but there was research
that came out of uh in part out of La
Jolla
um that said that and then you know the
authors of that were like oh but no
maybe not but like like it was actually
in the press release and so like let's
put it this way it was neither you nor
Robert Malone nor us on Dark Horse
um you know we're even postulating we
were we were we were repeating something
that had been published
it was obvious from the point that we
knew what Spike protein did that it was
a highly biologically active molecule
and therefore at the very least if you
think that your alteration of that
molecule has disarmed it the burden of
proof is very definitely on you it is
not misdis or malinformation no maybe
it's Mal information by that absurd
definition but
it is not miss or disinformation to just
simply note that this High highly
biologically active molecule
which is cytotoxic was an unfortunate
choice for a therapeutic That was
supposed to make you healthier and in
any case I guess my point is we are now
years down the road from an episode in
which officialdum no doubt driven by The
Who CDC maybe the White House we don't
know decided to crack down on US
citizens biologists simply saying clear
things into a camera that we were not
allowed to say we are living in the era
of officially designated wrong think
true things have been designated wrong
think and we actually have powerful
forces going after citizens for simply
remarking on what is in front of them
and that is a terrifying place to be it
is and it reminds me too of something
else there's many other things that
should be on the list of what am I
actually concerned about on a day
designated Earth Day
um as opposed to the gimmicky do nothing
virtue signaling things like sign this
petition uh things like the near
yeah
well you know nicotinoid
insecticides and uh the glyphosates and
the
um synthetic mRNA and meat and the
building roads and the Deep Wilderness
um
maybe stop making Franken viruses in
labs
how about that
well obviously I think that one's on the
list it's the top of the list because
the you know the self amplifying nature
of viruses means that this is not like a
pollutant it's far worse
um so that that is a uh a huge danger
and we have just suffered a massive
self-inflicted wound that if it is not a
wake-up call then we are unwakable so
yes clearly clearly we should be doing
that
um I also want to just say
the theme of our book is hyper novelty
we clearly have a pathology that is
built of hyper novelty and gain of
function research is one example of a
particularly potent way in which we do
inflict wounds on ourselves but
there are so many and one problem is
that we are
just simply addicted to the idea that
um progress is normal
normal and relatively comprehensible and
therefore if something seems like it
might be good let's do it and then when
we routinely find out that something
that we made a decent argument for
turned out to be bad we are we've got to
stop being surprised by that yeah and
now I've been thinking about the label
progressivism
right which is something that
I always thought of myself as a
progressive as as did you and
I never ever imagined
the people who thought of themselves the
progressives
thought
anything labeled as progress is good
anything that has been done before is
bad
but that seems to be that that one-two
punch of idiocy seems to be the thing
that is masquerading as progressivism
now as opposed to
understand
diagnose and work hard to maintain that
which has been done before and which is
still working
and assess carefully and do not proceed
if you can't undo and employ the
precautionary principle
those things that might allow us to
become better in some important way in
the future that's the progress part
most of the ideas that most people have
aren't good the idea that all you have
to do is slap a label on it this is
progress and then we're going to say yes
well that's how you get to team loser
that's a really quick route to team
loser right there
is also true that we are playing a
different game now because of the way we
are integrated together it's one thing
if and this is you know the
conservatives have a bunch of stuff
right they're more reluctant about
changing things up just for the sake of
doing it and they are also obsessed with
choice
to the extent that some group of people
thinks that some new thing might be
great that's fine anytime it's like
school choice
a choice to do or not it's just a choice
on its own there is a little jarring
because the usually when people say
choice in a political context they mean
exactly the thing the conservatives are
usually not interested in having choice
about yeah what I really mean is Liberty
right and the point is
when you mandate a vaccine for the
entire human race you are taking a new
kind of risk right because the point is
if it turns out that you're a numbskull
and that That vaccine isn't a vaccine
and it isn't safe and it isn't warranted
then you haven't left anybody in the
group of people who
doesn't suffer the consequences so it is
you know this is also true with
externalities right you can say that
your pollutant isn't a problem and the
point is you know Europe because we
can't measure it doesn't mean you didn't
cause problems right and so you know
it's when you're doing something new
it's the precautionary principle when
you're eliminating something old it's
jesterton's fence these things belong
squarely in our thinking because we live
in a complex system and the chances that
we understand what's going to happen
when we add something or subtract
something are are very low until it's
been done which should also make us very
concerned about anything that we're told
everybody's got a do the new thing or
stop doing the old thing or whatever
which I had two more things I wanted to
say before we close out here I have the
sense that's where we're headed one is
that my conversation this week with Mary
Harrington yeah
um I forgot to say something about top
of the hour rarely on this topic so she
lays out uh especially so she's got she
it's already out or she's about to have
coming out this book uh feminism against
progress
terrific highly recommend it and I have
not listened to your conversation yet
but she's terrific she is terrific and I
will say she was especially good I
always worry when somebody has written a
book I worry about us in this regard too
I think we've done well but when you've
written a book and you've laid out a
thesis and then something changes or how
good are you at acknowledging that
actually that book represented a
position in time but your your actual
position has has evolved
Mary was excellent on this front right
we actually had a honest-to-goodness
disagreement over whether or not
progress is real and should be expected
and I think we both enjoy the
conversation uh quite a bit and anyway I
really appreciate her willingness to
participate in a very live fashion you
know questioning stuff in a book that
isn't even out yet
um
so check out that podcast second thing
so it's about to come out yeah May 1st
or something this week I think
[Music]